Tap, ¿sí o no? ¿No?
¿El futuro Centro del Vasco linaric Center en gross
sí o no? ¿Eh? Sí, pero el
seguramente el emplazamiento no es el más adecuado.
¿Qué modelo lingüístico elige?
A, ¿b o d?
D estaría a favor de 1 parque eólico
en su municipio de residencia,
¿siempre y cuando
responda a los intereses de la comunidad y y respete
la ordenación del territorio?
Qué prioriza a soberanía,
¿b cuidados o c? ¿Economía?
Son cuestiones que no están confrontadas.
¿Necesitamos soberanía para hacer políticas públicas
del siglo 21? ¿Móviles en el Cole?
¿Hay que prohibirlos? Em,
yo diría que sí.
¿Considera que Donostia
necesita 1 Nuevo pabellón multiusos?
¿Pues no lo sé porque realmente no conozco la
el sistema de equipamientos
deportivos de Donostia?
¿Me parece que en general
eh? Tenemos bastante equipamiento y bastantes servicios
construidos. ¿Ya hay que mejorar la calidad?
¿Quitaría la deducción por compra de vivienda
para fomentar el alquiler?
Yo creo que sí,
¿porque somos la única
autónoma del estado que mantiene esa deducción?
¿Igualdad
considera que hay que establecer cuotas de paridad
en las ejecutivas de los partidos? Sí.
Y por último, ¿tiene seguro privado o de salud?
Lo tuve y lo he dejado de tener porque la
pérdida de la de la cavidad de
de del sistema público nos ha llevado a mucha gente
a tener que recurrir a otras opciones ante problemas
eh graves de salud